all right breaking news tonight
according to the AP Joe Biden has now
narrowed his VP search to six contenders
the shortlist would include Florida rep
Val Deming senator Elizabeth Warren
Obama's former National Security Advisor
Susan Rice
Atlanta mayor Lance and by the way
Kamala Harris New Mexico Governor
Michelle Lujan Grisham by the way the
list leaves off some often mentioned
names like Stacey Abrams Michigan
Governor all shut down Whitmer but the
list is apparently fluid according to a
Biden campaign and what they're saying
is now there have been so many gasps by
a sleepy joe 303 302 on this program
introduced a new recurring segment just
to try to keep up it's not gonna be easy
and it will feature the Biden blunder of
the week take a look have you ever
considered what would happen if the
election results came out as you being
the winner and Trump refused to leave
yes I have and I was so damn proud here
you have four Chiefs of Staff coming out
and ripping the skin off of Trump and
you have so many rank-and-file military
personnel saying whoa we're not a
military state this is not who we are
I promise you I'm absolutely convinced
they will escort him from the White
House in a version with great dispatch
all right military will escort him out
of the White House no wonder former DNC
chairman Terry McAuliffe said um no I'm
fine with him in the basement he's got
he sees two people a day is body people
take a look people say all the time oh
we got to get the vice president of a
basement he's fine in the basement two
people see him a day he's too bad a
people asset and let Trump keep doing
what trumps doing it's hard for the vice
president to break through I'm fine he's
leaving the basement he the two people
see him all day it's body people
president had a pointed response to the
ever forgetful Joe Biden's claims that
the president wants to steal the
election Oh
the next witch hunt it's on its way and
he wouldn't leave the White House if he
was defeated in an interview earlier
with her own harris faulkner that aired
today take a look
look just not all there everybody knows
it and it said when you look at it and
you see it you see it for yourself he's
created his own sanctuary city in the
basement of wherever he is and he
doesn't come out and certainly if I
don't win I don't win I mean you know go
on and two other things I think would be
a very sad thing for our country yes sad
compassionate president here's more of
Biden's blunders take a look
the failure to respond to the pandemic I
think the federal government has
advocated any effective leadership role
the White House at least has advocated
that role you know the rapidly rising in
with with I don't know it's just
inability to focus on any federal
responsibilities